look uh with the people that we've
spoken to i'd say the most of them do
know that there are changes they
couldn't list all of them because who
can there are about 50 rules that have
been either added or amended across nine
sections of the highway code so this is
going to be the new updated highway code
which comes into force today it's
important to note that these aren't
obligatory measures so you won't get
fined if you don't comply but
it is hoped that drivers and indeed all
road users will adhere to them and
follow these guidelines to try and make
roads safer here and there they range
from all different things there's the
the dutch reach you might have heard
about in the last few days which
involves using your left arm to open
your driver's side door or your right if
you're opening the passenger side dawn
the aim of that is to try and get people
to turn their body so that they can
check around them
before they open doors in case they
might hit a cyclist or a pedestrian we
spoke to some people here in richmond
park today have a listen to what they
had to say
generally good yeah i think people need
to give
cyclists a bit of space
and not get too close to them well i'm
totally in favor we drive around in
metal boxes to protect us
um cyclists haven't got that giving uh
cyclists
more awareness and more sort of space on
the road is definitely a good thing
assuming that the cars know they will
change because on the commute some are
good some are bad so
if they don't think if they think
they've got right away they're just
going to cut across you
let me just go through the new
guidelines with you the guidelines
states that traffic should give way when
pedestrians are looking to cross at a
junction
it says cyclists should ride in the
center of lanes on quieter roads in
slower moving traffic and when
approaching junctions to make themselves
as visible as possible
and is introducing a hierarchy of road
users drivers will have more
responsibility towards those on bikes
horses or on foot and cyclists will have
to be more aware of pedestrians now
there are some concerns that some
drivers might stick too rigidly to these
rules stopping all of a sudden to let a
pedestrian cross the road and possibly
getting hit from behind but there are
also concerns that not enough people are
aware of the changes with a recent
survey saying 33 of respondents didn't
know that the changes were coming in
place and 4 of those
said they weren't willing to look them
up